[Music]
on this friday night russia's heinous
attack on a busy ukrainian train station
they hit people with missiles the
carnage the kremlin's denials and new
video revealing the remnants of an
obliterated town
pushing back against russian propaganda
the war against disinformation during
the war in ukraine budget impact reality
checking ottawa's affordable housing
strategy we need a little bit more room
plus the new incentives for oil giants
to get greener faster
and batter up
something to cheer about on the diamond
and beyond
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us
russia is being accused of committing
yet another horrific war crime this time
at a railway station in eastern ukraine
where thousands of people were waiting
to evacuate the increasingly volatile
region and a warning our coverage
includes some disturbing images the
scene of horror unfolded this morning as
civilians were waiting to flee the city
of kramatorsk in the contested donetsk
region no ukrainian troops were said to
be at the station when the two rockets
hit at least 50 people were killed
including several children
world leaders have condemned the attack
but the kremlin is denying any
involvement going so far as to blame
ukraine for the terror caused on the
ground it comes as a top eu official
landed in kiev today with the pledge to
try to speed up ukraine's bid to become
a member of the bloc crystal command
singh begins our coverage tonight
a grisly scene in ukraine captured by
witnesses screams in panic have become
familiar but this
was something much worse
there were many killed and injured here
it was hell on earth bodies covered the
pavement some died instantly others
suffered wounds that will change their
lives forever
this is the kind of shrapnel pieces
scattered says his kramatorsk city
official people were injured by these
pieces that's what killed them
the railway station in the donesk oblast
was packed when it was hit by a missile
around 10 30 friday morning an estimated
4 000 people were in the area ukrainians
in the region had been instructed to get
out by any means necessary before the
fighting intensified
photos from the scene showed bodies
covered with tarps and the remnants of a
rocket with the words for the children
painted on it in russian
russia denies the attack as it has many
others claiming ukraine fired on its own
people
people were waiting for a train to get
to safe territory the ukrainian
president told finland's parliament
in bucha investigators are painstakingly
unearthing unmarked graves as they work
to identify the victims it's alleged
russian forces who occupied the area
just outside of the capitol for weeks
murdered civilians and then buried them
before retreating
ursula
is the first western politician to visit
the city and the site
it left her shakens the unthinkable has
happened here we have seen the
cool face
of um
putin's army we saw our humanity being
shattered thunderline and zelensky
discussed moving up ukraine's eu
membership bid when they met in kiev
potentially advancing that timeline from
years to weeks vonderlein says she
believes in ukraine marching towards a
european future while sanctions erode
russia as we know it
colleen
crystal command sing crystal thank you
we are learning more tonight about
another kiev's suburb that was occupied
by russian forces for several weeks and
now as ukrainians are making their way
back to bordeanca officials are warning
the situation is even more dreadful than
what occurred in bucha mike armstrong
takes us through what's left of the town
it is a town like so many others like
too many others reduced in parts to
rubble
borodyanka had a population before the
war of about 13 000. that's the size of
summerside pei port hope ontario kenmore
alberta or aldergrove bc
now what all of those places share with
this one is this
main street just flying over it doesn't
let you appreciate how everything that
was here was like what most of us know
wherever we live
so
starting out at the traffic circle
there's a restaurant on the right
sasha's place has a facebook page you
can see their courtyard their food
and their staff
behind sasha's there was a building
supply store there are some great
reviews online the owner natalka could
get you anything and you'd apparently be
pleasantly surprised by the prices
further up there was a small gourmet
grocery store the sort of place you
might go if you needed a special
ingredient on the left side there was a
hardware store part of a chain judging
from the pictures the sort of place my
brother would like moving on there was a
beer store on the right a place called
bar boss directly across from a health
clinic by the way hobo medical with all
the specialists you might need if you
were looking for a cell phone that was a
bit further up keefstar seems to have
had a decent selection there was also a
good selection at the butcher shop
across the street a block from there
another hardware store this one with an
interesting name mario's hardware yes
that mario there was another beer store
but this one a little different you
could buy draft from the
the local tax office was just up the
street and then a sports store a very
crowded and colorful sports store which
brings us to the town square it's
another thing most communities have and
in the case of bordyanka in the middle
there was a statue ukrainian poet and
artist taras chavchenko
this is what that square looks like
today and how that statue was left with
a bullet hole in the head and looking
down almost as though trying not to see
what happened here according to
ukrainian officials russian troops
killed 300 people in boardienko 50 of
them
executed
mike armstrong global news
ukraine is one of the world's biggest
bread baskets and new data shows the
hefty toll the fighting is already
having on food prices the u.n says world
food prices hit an all-time high in
march soaring nearly 13 percent above
february's record high the price for
cereals including wheat and other coarse
grains is up 17
the u.n says food prices were already at
a 10-year high before the war
in this country some good news more
people are finding work national
unemployment hit a record low last month
canada's economy added 73 000 jobs in
march mostly in ontario and quebec
pushing the unemployment rate down to
5.3 percent that's the lowest rate since
statistics canada started tracking the
data in 1976 and it's the first time
it's fallen to its pre-pandemic level
average hourly wages are also up
slightly 3.4 percent on a year-over-year
basis
employed or not many canadians are still
struggling to keep up with soaring rents
and real estate prices the trudeau
government is targeting housing
affordability as a key priority in its
budget but experts wonder if ottawa can
turn the plans into reality david aiken
reports
living in a downtown apartment has been
great for liz rashid haggy but now with
baby gwen quickly growing it's time to
move on up we have our dog and my
husband and i and our baby and there's a
lot of stuff to to house so we need a
little bit more room the barrier to that
move though a fiercely competitive
market with sky-high prices people are
just coming in and it seems like pulling
numbers out of thin air
and we're not getting much of an
opportunity to offer within our price
range
families like liz's are precisely the
kind that the trudeau government had in
mind when it unveiled a raft of new
programs in the budget to make housing
more affordable in a country like canada
we should be able to make sure that
people who work hard
who want to start a family
in communities they love
should be able to find a home
most experts admire the ambition in the
budget but the money to match that
ambition may not be there the promise to
double the number of houses completed
over the next decade is a very ambitious
target
i don't think there's enough policy here
to make that a reality that the spending
towards that is relatively modest
the budget also promised a home buyer's
bill of rights it would for example
outlaw the practice of blind bidding
where competing prospective buyers are
not told about the value of other bids
and as promised in their election
platform liberals will ban foreign
investment in residential real estate
for two years but that may only have a
limited effect a lot of the speculation
is is domestic in nature and this really
doesn't touch it
in any event liz rashid haggie and her
family cannot wait for new federal
programs to have an impact so she's
house hunting in communities 60 70 80
kilometers from work we've had no choice
but to look as far as arm pryor and
perth and smith's falls
places that are you know an hour outside
the city
and then is the price savings
enough to offset the price of gas right
now it's
we can't win david aiken global news
ottawa
keeping costs down for canadians will be
another major challenge for ottawa is it
attempts to curb the climate crisis eric
sorensen reports on the task of growing
the economy while protecting the
environment
it's been a head-spinning week for this
country's balancing act as a
climate-protecting oil-producing nation
there were new federal investments to
make gm a major electric vehicle
manufacturer then approval of baidu nord
off newfoundland and labrador that'll
bring some 300 million more barrels of
oil into the world
capped off by a federal budget furiously
trying to lead this country from old
energy to new endless
finance minister christian freeland laid
out urgent new investments zero
emissions vehicles a novelty not long
ago may well be the next car or truck
you buy by 2030 manufacturers must sell
mostly zero emissions vehicles car
buyers have a five thousand dollar
incentive for another three years and
companies will soon get inducements to
switch their truck fleets to zero
emissions accelerating electric vehicle
adoption is a clear win-win for canada
it's an area where we're going to be
able to reduce emissions dramatically
and
set up
a new create new jobs and economic
growth but ottawa did not abandon oil
and gas many oil giants have banded
together to develop carbon capture and
storage in western canada and now ottawa
is offering two and a half billion
dollars in tax credits to ramp up
investments quickly the six big oil
sense companies came together we said we
can't do a little and
um yesterday's budget with the
investment tax credit clearly a key step
in getting us to where we need to go
critics say capturing carbon doesn't
discourage burning more fossil fuels if
you want to secure our future that
begins first and foremost by tackling
those direct emissions
from fossil fuels energy and industry
the federal budget shows the challenge
for ottawa to reduce emissions without
pulling the rug from under the oil and
gas sector it shows that the government
can balance multiple objectives not only
to decarbonize which is critical but
also to maintain economic growth and as
ottawa invests in e-vehicles while
simultaneously supporting oil production
it can expect ongoing criticism from all
sides eric sorensen global news toronto
courting high hopes coming up the
significance of katangi brown jackson's
appointment to the u.s supreme court
and the punishment will smith just got
slapped with for that smack heard around
the world
it was a day of celebration and
reflection in washington where the u.s
has just marked an historic first judge
katangi brown jackson has been confirmed
to that country's supreme court becoming
the first black woman to serve as
justice as jackson proskow reports it's
hoped she'll bring a new perspective to
the highest court in the u.s
the gravity of this moment clearly
weighed on america's newest supreme
court justice i am the dream and the
hope
of the slave
as katanji brown jackson was welcomed at
the white house she entered the history
books blazing a trail on the highest
court in the u.s in my family it took
just one generation to go from
segregation to the supreme court of the
united states
jackson's nomination and confirmation
fulfill a long-standing promise from
president joe biden who vowed to appoint
the first black woman to the court
writing a historic lack of
representation we're going to look back
and see this as a moment of real change
in american history and this nomination
is confirmed her confirmation was
overseen by the first black woman to
serve as vice president she secured a
slim bipartisan majority in the senate
thursday
as democrats applauded most republicans
filed out of the room in silence they
spent weeks protesting her candidacy
it's not a matter of her being a black
woman that's extra
if she were a white woman or a white
male she would still be highly qualified
for the court this may be the most
transformative moment since thurgood
marshall became the first black justice
in 1967
adding perspective not simply because of
her race and gender but because of her
experience
judge jackson was also a former public
defender
which means she knows what it is like to
represent the little person her arrival
won't change the balance of power on the
conservative leaning court
when she officially joins the bench this
summer she will face some of the most
important cases in a generation abortion
rights voting rights and environmental
protections
judge jackson has not only earned her
place in american history she will now
help chart it jackson prosco global news
washington
will smith has been banned from
attending the oscars for 10 years the
decision was made today by the academy
of motion pictures arts and sciences it
comes nearly two weeks after smith
walked on stage and slapped chris rock
after rock made a joke about smith's
wife jada pinkett smith
smith went on to win the oscar for best
actor he'll be allowed to keep that
award smith says he understands and
respects the ban
david and goliath in the digital age
ahead one man's crusade to fight
disinformation on social media
[Music]
you're watching global national
[Music]
russian president vladimir putin's first
weapon in the war against ukraine was
the spread of propaganda amplified by
state media outlets online
for the new reality this week our jeff
semple is reporting on the crusade to
crack down on hate and disinformation
swirling on social media jeff
in the background of the war raging in
ukraine is another battle against online
disinformation and washington dc is on
the front lines of that fight we came
here to meet imran ahmed who leads the
center for countering digital hate the
non-profit campaigns for governments and
big tech firms to crack down on hate
speech and disinformation and lately
they've had their hands full putin has
invaded a sovereign country and the
first weapons he used in that war
against ukraine were not missiles or
tanks it was disinformation and lies
spread through propaganda on social
media including this one from russian
state media on facebook falsely claiming
the u.s is funding secret bio-weapons
labs in ukraine ahmed's team examined
1300 facebook posts from russian state
media and found the social media giant
had failed to label 91 percent of the
posts as russian propaganda
a spokesperson for facebook's parent
company called ahmed's findings wildly
inaccurate noting the examples represent
just a fraction of all posts about
russia and ukraine facebook for years
have been saying that they're going to
label content from propaganda channels
there's a big gap between what the
platforms say and they do and those
seeking to sow hatred and misinformation
now have a new platform
ahmed's team recently went undercover in
virtual reality fake dragon intestines
this third-party facebook app where
users interact in a virtual world his
team witnessed verbal abuse from racism
to sexual assault occurring on average
every seven minutes they're gonna have
to put in a lot of work to get this
as somewhere where parents would feel
safe leaving their kids because right
now you don't want mark zuckerberg
babysitting your kids a spokesperson for
metta told global news they're rolling
out new safety measures including new
parental supervision tools to prevent
children from unlocking adult content
jeff semple global news washington
you can watch jeff's full report on the
fight against disinformation tomorrow
night at 8 on the new reality right here
on global
coming up the blue jays are back but
baseball isn't the only pro sport
creating excitement in canada's biggest
city
three
two
one zero ignition
stop go falcons go dragon got speed
actually
and with that the first all private crew
of astronauts is on its way to the
international space station the spacex
crew dragon is expected to reach the iss
tomorrow and spend eight days on board
this is the first mission for axiom a
u.s company that hopes to build a
commercial space station
there's nothing quite like baseball's
home opener in toronto all the
excitement as fans watch the blue jays
get back into the swing of the season
especially now that coveted restrictions
have been lifted but as mike delay
explains it's the energy being felt on
the field the ice and the court that has
sports fans in canada's biggest city
buzzing
there's an odd feeling in toronto right
now call it optimism at least when it
comes to sports the blue jays are
expected to be good so good in fact that
when the oddity that makes bobachet's
bobblehead unique was unveiled it
actually has real hair nobody asked
whose hair
it certainly didn't come from bose
flowing locks which looked dazzling as
ever as he spoke about the overwhelming
opinion within baseball that the jays
will make a run at the world series i
think we've expected a lot more out of
ourselves than any of you guys have
in the past so
for us i mean i think it's more of a
just kind of about time this is the
first home opener in toronto in three
years because of covid close to 50 000
fans are expected with the six wave and
no masking requirements there may be
nerves off the field too the j's players
themselves can only control what's
happening between the lines and to a man
they're thankful to only have one home
field this year after splitting 2021
between dunedin florida buffalo and
toronto it's not the actual home
ballpark it's being able to wake up in
your own condo and make breakfast by
yourself make your own coffee go take a
shirt out of your closet instead of your
suitcase on the floor just for once all
the excitement around opening day
doesn't erase how difficult these last
two years have been kovid hasn't
provided many laughs however toronto
sports fans may get a chuckle out of
this because unvaccinated players on
us-based teams will continue to be
turned away at the border until
restrictions are eased if it's a star
player for the red sox or yankees that's
a huge advantage for the blue jays
it's not the uh not the blue jays
pulling a fast one on anybody they have
just
been fully vaccinated and are able to
travel freely perhaps 2022 is the year
toronto teams put it all together the
raptors are playing better than anyone
expected austin matthews just set a
maple leafs record for goals in a season
and the boys of summer are back
it must finally be spring microlight
global news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday night i'm colleen christie we
leave you tonight in toronto with a
sneak peek of the warm-up inside rogers
center thanks for watching sophie louis
will be at the anchor desk tomorrow
let's go jays
[Music]